Kevin mccarthy es un hombre de 57 años
que vive en un Distrito conservador en
el estado demócrata por excelencia
California desde que llegó a Washington
en 2007 quiere presidir la cámara de
representantes en 2015 casi gana la
Silla cuando el republicano johner
anunció su renuncia pero los choques con
los representantes del freedom Cocos el
ala más conservadora de los republicanos
se lo impidieron los mismos que ahora se
han opuesto a que sea elegido cuando la
entonces presidenta de la cámara Nancy
pelosi inició uno de los juicios
políticos contra Donald Trump mccarthy
fue uno de los que se opuso
la presidenta pelosi es la presidenta de
esta cámara pero no habla por Estados
Unidos cuando se trata de este tema no
puede decidir unilateralmente lo que
sucede aquí han estado investigando a
este presidente incluso antes de que
fuera electo han votado tres veces sobre
juicio político Aquí
también hizo eco de las acusaciones
infundadas de fraude de Trump al perder
la presidencia y llamó a un recuento de
los votos
cada recuento debe terminarse tenemos
desafíos dentro de los tribunales cada
demanda debe ser escuchada
independientemente de a quien apoye en
esta elección al final del día queremos
que Estados Unidos esté Unido
Aunque republicano condenó el asalto al
Capitolio y denunció el comportamiento
de Donald Trump semanas después fue amar
al agua retractarse y a intentar
recuperar el aprecio del hombre que una
vez le llamó mi Kevin el portavoz de la
cámara de representantes es la tercera
persona con más poder en Estados Unidos
tras el presidente Joe biden den y la
vicepresidenta kamala Harris